because of the Asians that are getting
beat kalila man I have another bone to
pick it's I I think that what's
happening to agents is so [ __ ]
ignorant but especially you know here's
the thing
they got it all right we can we can we
promise one thing after five more
minutes of this I think that everyone
right now is so like just kind of
overwhelmed with too much like a lot of
things I want to talk things I want to
talk to you about
let's go light an area after this let's
go like back to our cities yeah we will
but this is the first one we've done you
know under the panty and I think we
should think it we should talk about a
little bit longer okay all right but the
thing is is that you know what Americans
have to understand is that you know
Asian dudes that live here that are born
here right you because I saw up some
video at a Walmart somewhere in the
Midwest where some Asian American guy
coughed and people confronted them it's
like dude it's like hey let me say I'm
48 years old
all right and if you're 46 I've been at
American longer than you all right
how old are you George 40 right longer
than me for eight years all right
I'm merit an American thrown through I
bleed and poo red white and blue I love
this country so much this is all I know
I don't know [ __ ] about Asia right so
when you know I haven't obviously I
haven't been outside and I haven't been
being I haven't been confronted by you
know I have a question about the red
white think they own those colors
because the Philippines has red white
and blue and just about maybe a hundred
of 30 other countries why do we own that
we don't own in the wide red white and
blue like should be like the the we
called this script descriptor [ __ ] out
50 stars yes that's it
maybe that's add that's more American 50
I think we got the we have the country
songs that sing red white and blue so I
think that's how we want it does
through a lot of country songs and
nobody else wants country songs about
their uh the colors of their flag so
they'll go other things okay okay but I
just want to make a point that could
just go back to you yeah you're an
American not only am I an American it's
it's like you know what happened I don't
know what happened to Mohan I don't know
how this [ __ ] started I don't want to
make you know I wasn't there I love the
way you said it like a country star who
hands but you you don't think that I you
don't think I being an Asian American
guy go what the [ __ ] happened you know
like I am angry about it as well right
I'm in the same boat as any other
American about this disease I have no
idea how it started
I'm sure I mean there were there were a
lot of things that went wrong right to
contain it I think that China could have
done different steps to to be more
transparent about the disease up front
but my point is is that when you're her
if you harass some random asian-american
dude about this disease we're as
confused as you are we're the same as
you is what I'm saying
yeah hey guys sorry to interrupt but we
had this amazing spot you want to share
with you
Hamptons hymns if you're a guy you need
to do it together guys